men who were really a bunch of perverts
in your locker room in your bathroom
because they listen
they want to have sex with you that's
why they're in there that's real they're
it's not they're not saying oh I
identify as a woman and I'm only
attracted to men that is a lie
these are sexual predators they're
sexual predators
do you really think that actual violent
predators are going to be dissuaded by
the gender sign on the bathroom door
it's absurd and ridiculous and of course
when then you go further and say Well
there must be hundreds or thousands or
at least dozens of incidents where based
on a falsely stated gender identity
someone hid out in a bathroom and then
assault you find out that it is
essentially non-existent and it is all
part of the story that they use to prop
up this anti-trends anti-trans paranoia
that they are now obsessed with and that
they are raising money around at the end
of the day